number four is the nfc east whoever wins
the nfc east
is going to get the fourth seed and get
that home game in the playoffs and you
can see the big development here today
is washington washington getting the win
against san francisco meanwhile the
giants losing to arizona
today so suddenly it's washington a game
up on the giants and look at this
a 71 percent shot that washington will
make the playoffs the giants now under
20 percent
by the way eagle span soar you got that
huge upset win over the saints
a lot of good that did you took it from
six percent to 11
chance it's washington now in the last
week they beat pittsburgh
they beat san francisco they watched the
giants
get beat by the cardinals and suddenly
it's washington
with a chance to pull away and win the
nfc east and get the home game that
comes with it in the playoffs
all right there's steve kornacki taking
a look at the breakdown from
the nfc east let's talk about the teams
in the nfc east and
how they stack up as we get to crunch
time
in the 2020 season the washington
football team now
controls their destiny or their fate
it's
we're always very careful about not
saying you control your destiny because
no one can control
their destiny they control their their
playoff outcome
if they win out they win the division if
they stumble it opens the door for the
giants because the giants hold the
tiebreaker
alex smith though is the key now ron
rivera the coach of the washington
football team said after the game that
smith was removed for the second half of
the win over the 49ers as a precaution
we'll see what the injury report says
they'll go with dwayne haskins if they
have to but
it really seemed like the team had
fallen out of love
with haskins now they may have to
embrace him
at least for one week shireen
it's crazy mike the quarterbacks that
that every team in this division has
gone through
i mean even the giants who've had their
starter most this season started colt
mccoy
but you just look around at it you know
washington has now
started three quarterbacks and the
cowboys have started four quarterbacks
and the eagles have started two
quarterbacks and the giants have started
two quarterbacks so it's crazy and i
think it says a lot about why this
division is
is where it is and i'm curious what you
think of this though
does is the winner of this division
really the loser
because they now can't draft any higher
than 19th
do you think that's the case in this
division
i think that and and you can call me
crazy if you want
i think that you should never
look down your nose at the opportunity
to play a playoff game
because next year if your team is better
the players will have playoff experience
and maybe you'll get lucky
and win the game right when the panthers
made it at seven eight and one when ron
rivera was the head coach six years ago
they won and then they went to seattle
now now they beat
ryan lindley the cardinals back up to
the backup quarterback but still they
won
they went to seattle and they gave the
seahawks everything they could handle so
i think that it's
it's oh and what happened the next year
the panthers were wired to wire the best
team in the nfc and they almost won the
super bowl so
i think if you get the opportunity to
play playoff games
that's more valuable to your full locker
room than getting a higher
draft pick in the various rounds i i
would always take the chance
to roll the dice on the post season
because you never know what's going to
happen we assume that the five seed is
going to go to washington or new york or
philadelphia or
god forbid dallas i'm kidding and and uh
and when
easily we don't know what's going to
happen maybe the home team is going to
win
even though as we'll talk later in the
program there may not be much of a home
field advantage this year
well the crazy thing to me mike is when
i look at each of these teams
washington is the one team i think can
really benefit from exactly what you're
talking about is getting
to the postseason and playing a playoff
game because
their that defense is really good i mean
we've we've seen that
they to me need fewer additions for next
season
going into next season i just think you
know if alex smith is going to be your
quarterback and you've determined that
and you'll
possibly get to see haskins maybe this
week to see if you still have
confidence in that he can do the job and
i know
that kyle allen is beloved by ron rivera
we all know that that's why i brought
him with them
from carolina but they to me look like
the one team that could really benefit
from that from
ron rivera building that program the
other three teams to me
seem to have a ton of holes and could
really use the higher draft pick and i
get what you're saying though
you always want to win you always want
to go to the playoffs and it is
beneficial to go to the playoffs
but if i'm those other three teams i'm
probably
in the end if i don't make the
postseason i'm grateful for that high
draft pick because i have a lot of holes
to fill
well you're absolutely right about that
and the thing is these four teams are
going to be competing next year
in the same division so whoever fills
the most holes may be
in the best position to take over the
nfc east
the giants yesterday when they lost at
home to the arizona cardinals and
if you listened earlier to the hassan
redick interview
he made it clear that the cardinals
understood the stakes they
they had energy all week long in
practice they knew what they had to do
to get themselves back into the playoff
chase
the giants on the other hand seemed flat
and it seemed like daniel jones
shouldn't have played and look serene
i'm not a physical therapist i'm not a
doctor but i have had a hamstring injury
and i know that two weeks is not enough
time to get it to the point
where you can go out and push off of it
and
the other loose understanding that i
have with the hamstring injury
the higher the pull the harder it is to
get it healed and
daniel jones was grabbing pretty high on
the hamstring when he injured it against
the
bengal specifically when he aggravated
after they put him back in the game
i don't think he had any business being
out on the field and they're going to
pay for it now because it very well may
be colt mccoy going against his former
team the cleveland browns
on sunday night but in their zeal to try
to stay in it and go with their best guy
they made the miscalculation that 100
colt mccoy is better than
less than 100 daniel jones when you're
running the risk that he's going to come
out of it
even farther less than 100 than he was
well mike i think you saw it on his
first throw he had a wide open receiver
and i can't remember who the receiver
was might have been slayton but wide
open receiver and he throws it behind
him has a reach back and
ended up completing the pass because it
was a great catch but you saw that he
just didn't have
that ability to push off on that
hamstring on the very first play
and what makes daniel jones daniel jones
is his ability to run
he's second on the team and rushing and
he's second on the team and rushing for
a reason because he's really good when
he gets outside the pocket that to me is
the strength of his
and he wasn't able to do that and if he
wasn't able to do that i don't know why
you played him you give him another week
to heal
you like colt mccoy who won a huge game
for you the week before
continue that momentum let him play rely
on that defense
and and try to win the game and i think
they would have had a better chance if
they had played
and started colt mccoy instead of daniel
jones and let daniel jones healed and i
think
long term name as you said they may have
to play colt mccoy now this week because
of what they did to daniel jones last
week
last year the philadelphia eagles were
five and seven before they finally
figured things out they got the big win
over the cowboys in week 16 which gave
them control of the division
all they had to do was beat the giants
week 17 which they did although that
game was closer than many thought it was
going to be
this year the eagles have commenced the
process during the final four games of
the season to start rattling off wins
the problem though shireen
is unlike last year when they were only
chasing one team
when you have two teams in front of you
you have to have
both teams stumble to give you the
opening which makes it much harder for
them
to duplicate what they did last year
they can win
the next three games but it doesn't
matter
if the giants or washington take care of
their
own business now they get an opportunity
to pick off washington
so they have some control there and
maybe week 17
sunday night football nbc will be
washington at philadelphia jalen hurts
versus alex smith ron rivera versus doug
peterson
a playoff play-in game maybe that's what
we'll see
that's what it could come down to but
they need the giants to continue to
slump and maybe the giants will as well
the giants don't have an easy road so
philadelphia isn't done yet but it's not
going to be easy for them because they
do have two teams not one to contend
with
yeah that's exactly right mike and i
think it might come down to that week 17
game but it's such a key
game this week for the eagles and i'm
looking forward to seeing jalen hurts
against kyler murray and seeing what he
can do and
of course the cardinals took care of the
giants will the cardinals take care of
the eagles
that's the key thing if the eagles can
win that game i certainly expect them to
beat the cowboys the next week and then
maybe it does come down
to that last week considering that
washington has seattle this week that's
another big game and
you know a couple weeks ago we were
looking at it thinking these
nfc east teams were playing some really
good teams and it looked like they were
all going to lose and
they've beaten some really good good
teams these these
at least the top three nfc east teams
have beaten some good teams over the
last couple weeks and really started to
play
much better and when i look at these
three teams when you look at where
they're ranked in offense and defense
they're a lot alike they rely on defense
they don't have a great quarterback they
kind of sort of
score enough points i mean you look at
washington scored two defensive
touchdowns they didn't even score an
offensive touchdown
but there's so much alike these three
teams that
it's going to come down to which one
could play the best defense arrests away
because we don't know what's going to
happen at the quarterback position for
any of these three teams they all have
questions at the quarterback position
and then there are your dallas cowboys
shireen they're not dead yet but
unlike the eagles they have three teams
that they have to jump
and jerry jones friday on 105 3 the fan
his word salad about why it's actually a
good thing
they were flexed out of sunday night
football they're still the biggest draw
in the nfl
period no no no they're not no they're
not you know we started at one point
today on pft live to talk about
their win over the bengals and sims and
i spontaneously decided
that no one cares no one cares at this
point
no one cares about the dallas cowboys
they're not dead yet
but it's pretty damn close because as we
said
they're in last place they've got to
jump three teams over the next three
weeks
it's highly unlikely just because they
beat the bengals doesn't mean that
they've solved their problems this is
something's going to take some
renovation in the offseason stephen
jones said today that
mike mccarthy's definitely coming back
he's surprised it's even a question well
if you're surprised
at the question you're not paying
attention and of course they're not
going to fire him as you have said they
don't want to buy out his contract it
would be roughly 24 million
over the next four years if they would
fire him and
uh they they don't want to admit they
were wrong so they're going to try to
make chicken salad this off season hope
to get dak prescott back hope to get him
signed and and hope that they can have a
better outcome next year jerry jones
said he'd like to get a mulligan
on 2020. i think in his mind 2021 is his
mulligan on 2020.
yeah my mike and the funny thing is all
my friends and neighbors who are cowboys
fans
texted it or i've seen some of them
today and they they're mad the cowboys
won
like they want that draft pick they were
fifth in the draft order
uh going into that game and of course
that hurts their draft order but they
want they want some defensive players
they want some defensive help on that
side of the football
to match these other teams dak prescott
was leading the league in passing and
they still had a losing record when they
had him
they have to get better on defense the
way to do that is have that high draft
pick and have your choice of who you
pick
defensively hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports